anyway welcome to this video my way with
black he plays Bishop b5 anyway yes that
wiki line where he snatches the pawn and
not this time okay that's how it places
yes looks very strange to play d4 in
this position the whites bet development
que Cree takes sd-6
so d60 doesn't mind it seems I'm not
threatening to take only five because my
queen is unprotected but still out 497
big temple this would then cake isn't
that possible I mean clearly 626 takes
on d6 Bishop see three wins wins apiece
so I should win something that's game 45
against my way and less cause just plus
6 it's not a lot okay so i can win
material now in more than one way I
guess this one and take a form
okay I cannot win more all right what
take with the bishop and that's not easy
let's do this I'm not sure both both is
good of course I've got this d 5 as we
cashier that's a bit of a problem
[Music]
so sure how I should develop here the
bishop will come here the light squares
are somewhat weak we can
yeah I'm sure
my DS Bishop c4 create and then push b5
here I'm also threatening a forum
because of that loose bishop so we have
to I think reacted some way otherwise I
will go in for yes this is one way I'm
ready 4 p-5
it's still not so easy in the porn isn't
held all that much at the moment it's
nice to have specific but it doesn't do
much at the moment okay so maybe this
end at five I Scott before in the in in
dec on the cards here should see success
a check before it's not before as
annoying
doesn't have a good discovery I think
still not my ideas efore hi Bishop d3
hope that isn't too ambitious very
ambitious but if it works it's really
really good and as all this activity if
it works yeah bishops III i have just
hope there is no tactic night eggs and
Queenie hive check and so on but don't
really see it working
there should be five years to check on
g6 so just go back completely yeah I've
got the chicken now yeah f4 is a queen
trade so 918 he has to do this which
isn't so ideal I just wonder if I have
something direct down and let's again
this this thing with the chick rookie
three maybe I only see that now still
tricky somehow even though I'm up tons
of material I ok it's an exchange in the
corn tonces a bit much he has to play
will be three hands kind of the only
tribe
that's a big pin okay let that should be
enough I'm always very is really
dangerous technician okay check
[Music]
checkmate okay oh and always tough even
after a good opening position you sir
always dangerous okay so i will sell
stuff yeah 95 95 now 98 yeah that should
be okay really I mean that's an awkward
pin right 27 is a threat and now is
already in some trouble yeah that's a
debatable decision and Bishop takes is
also quite um quite sensible maybe it's
better because the bishop has an
immediate scope
I wasn't sure the d6 porn doesn't look
so strong then but now I'm struggling a
little bit with the activity of whites
pieces unless I overlook stuff I think I
did a decent job ie4 immediately and
then Bishop c200 as a funny tactic
that's a funny tactic this and then
Bishop see to this nice but I hope that
this didn't blunder no this should takes
before me enjoy the comfort and rookie
three look more dangerous but I should
have it under control and queen d for
next ok mmm and hear things are things I
get it this is getting easy yeah always
tricky against my way thanks for
watching